Pakistan's former prime minister Imran
Khan is under arrest after a judge
sentenced him to three years in prison
on charges of corruption that means it's
likely he may not be able to contest
this year's elections Khan has called
for Nationwide protests Kamal Haider
reports from Islamabad
Pakistan's police came and then numbers
surrounding the home of former prime
minister Imran Khan and arresting him
a police Convoy took him to a prison in
the city of attack 85 kilometers from
Islamabad
the former Cricket return politician has
been found guilty of corruption and
sentenced to three years in jail for
selling State gifts
while he is appealing his conviction
it's one of more than 140 cases spending
against him
following his arrest Khan released a
pre-recorded message
my fellow pakistanis by the time this
message reaches you they will have
arrested me and I will be in jail I have
one request from you an appeal that you
do not sit in your homes quietly
whatever I am doing is not for myself I
am doing it for you
foreign
play aimed at keeping his political
party off the ballot what is behind all
this
the PDM and the establishment they are
petrified of Elections
they were Jubilation among his opponents
but his supporters the conviction and
arrest is applaud to stifle political
opposition
this arrest looks like it was planned
this won't end well this should have
been done in a proper way he was the
only one arrested what about the other
Angel politicians they have done a lot
of things
security remains tied in many regions of
Pakistan
as the government looks to prevent any
potential spots of violence the
country's information Minister says the
move is not politically motivated
however Imran Khan's legal team is now
going to challenge this in a court of
appeal on Monday Islamabad
well as Kamal was saying that Imran Khan
is facing more than a hundred legal
cases involving corruption and terrorism
in April last year he was ousted in a
no-confidence vote after his Coalition
Partners deserted him six months later
Pakistan's electoral commission
disqualified him from running for public
office for five years citing what it
called Corrupt Practices will Khan and
thousands of his supporters then set off
on a long march to Islamabad to demand
early elections he was shot in an
attempted assassination last November
police attempted to arrest him in March
this year but those warrants were later
canceled he was arrested again in May
but Pakistan's Supreme Court ruled it
illegal
well earlier my colleague Rob Matheson
spoke to the Pakistani Minister Sherry
Raymond he asked whether the government
is concerned by accusations at the case
against Khan is politically motivated
I don't think there can be political
engineering of how people think and what
they want to do with their time with
their vote with their support that's not
something we can interfere with what he
is doing though is serially inciting
people to violence to mob violence he's
used human Shields against his residence
in Zaman Park and my party's founding
leader has been extrajudicially hanged
but at no point did the People's Party
or any Democratic party ever think of
trying to lob bombs at our military or
installations or burn up public
ambulances because they were angry
because they are above the law so they
seem to think another kind of law
applies to them and and they kind of
live in you know the state is is
kind of sort of sense of
self-entitlement and you know that's
just not how it works anywhere in the
world I want to ask you about the the
upcoming elections that Pakistan is
going to be facing I understand standard
caretaker government is about to be put
into place given the fact that the the
leader and much of the leadership and
many of the supporters large numbers of
supporters of what is widely regarded as
the most popular party in Pakistan are
either in jail or facing jail or are
facing other charges how difficult is it
going to be to convince voters in
Pakistan that democracy does still exist
if the predominant opposition party
essentially is being divided and split
up so I don't think anywhere in the
world you know I take your point but
anywhere in the world is the predominant
opposition party which we've been for
many years or or a ruling party have we
ever thought that or anywhere in the
world can any party get away with uh
burning looting
both public properties the our public
Martyrs our military veterans our
military installation I don't think
that's considered
politics anywhere in the world from
where at least as I understand it